hello everyone I'd like to show you a
nice game played by Edward Lasker note
that this isn't Emanuel as per Google
champion but rather one of the distances
relatives so here's the game I'm just
okay
v4 f5 the Dutch descent not of three is
693 matter of six note that why played
93 bottom case see porn because he's
trying to get rapid development by
pushing efore pretty soon Bishop to g5
Bishop e7 Bishop takes f6 now white
captures the knight on f6 because the
the problem with the dodge defense is
that weakens the King side by the first
move f5 somewhat and now white decided
to remove one more defender from the
Kings side Bishop takes f6 and now we
for now here probably a better move
would be to play Knight d5 pawn to d5
but in the game SDXC for was played
which isn't quite good as it improves
the position of White Knight c3 Knight y
c3 Knight nice takes e4 and I'll be 736
black wants to play Bishop d7 and Castle
King side and use the F file and despite
them bag and offers Bishop Bishop to d3
Bishop to b7 and on 85 but a daring move
white is someone daring black to capture
he is night but also he doesn't really
mind because the black would be locked
in Bishop there as well but what problem
we should have captured here as those
white knights in the center of the board
or monsters but black decided to castle
and here we have Queen h5
and here is the decisive mistake in the
game by play
Sir Thomas plays 27 and here I'm sure
those of you who don't know the game can
still there's something wrong with the
position here and there's probably
something for white here and in fact
there is there is the very nice wind xh7
check and here black doesn't really have
any options beyond the f7 square is
covered by the night the only move he
can play except the Queen sacrifice
defects h7 and here comes the beautiful
combination bye laughter nice takes
if f6 double check if King h8 then
simply in Knight to g6 is checkmate
so King has to go to 86 and now 95 to g4
and here this was quite counterintuitive
because the other night it could also
have come to g4 but this is better
although it's leaning the f6 Knight
unprotected King to g5 h4 checks in to
f4 only move in 3:3 seems to f3 only
move and now Bishop e2 check King to g2
only move root 2 H to check and now King
goes all the way to do you want only
move and here Alaska finishes it off
which I came to D to checkmate last year
could have also played a nice queenside
castle checkmate this is also a very
nice you know checkmating your opponent
with a castle is always good although
Paul Morphy I think a couple of a couple
of months before this game was played
also finished one of his game with a
queenside castle so Alaska probably try
to avoid this Sandor
thought his game would be remembered
better if he finished it with Kim to d2
so this is a very nice mix it's a very
nice game I hope you enjoyed it and the
season